ich glaub glaubst nicht okay
ja klar klappt auf jeden fall endlich
ist es wieder soweit leute ich habe seit
dem letzten hilfen bio das ist schon ein
bisschen länger zurück liegt sehr viel
nachricht bekommen indem ich heute
gefragt haben wann kommt das nächste
hilfe wir würden gerne wieder ansehen
bei dir und ich lasse mich dann
natürlich nicht lumpen und habe heute
für euch eine frische hilfen erfolge am
start das werde ich in köln ist formel
eutm eine stimmung des mega
dementsprechend habe ich jetzt überaus
viel lust mir diese stimmung wieder von
einer grund beschissenen videoproduktion
versauern zu lassen ist das video heißt
25 jungen frau auch meine tochter
braucht dringend einen mann kann laut
beschreibung geht es darum dass die
konditorin heike mächtig stolz auf ihr
kind ist es gibt nur ein problem ihre
tochter ist 25 und also noch nie einen
freund der mir sicher heike wird dafür
eine sehr gute lösung finden
[Musik]
okay hier sehen wir also die
geburtstagsparty für heikes tochter und
ich glaub heike ist diese blonde dame da
ist ne nette auf jeden fall was mir
allerdings jetzt hier sofort auffällt
ist dass der kuchen etwas mysteriös
aussieht
was also die story dann muss ich sagen
macht mal wieder überhaupt keinen sinn
so es läuft überhaupt keine musik gehen
im raum ihre mutter fängt man an zu
tanzen und selbstverständlich hatten wir
recht leute eher der kuchen war
natürlich kein kuchen sondern nur ein
trojanisches pferd in dem sich ein
stripper versteckt hat das thema hat
dann natürlich ein luftballon in der
hand und schießt den weil das machen ja
stripper so ich bin ein bisschen
enttäuscht von dem streamer jetzt gehabt
so durchtrainiert der braungebrannte
mann wahrscheinlich oberkörperfrei mit
so einer fliege um den hals
es hat einfach so sieht ein bisschen
druck aus
[Musik]
ohne scheiße ich will jetzt wirklich
nicht schämen aber das ist das findest
trip weiter wisst ihr dass ausgedeutet
aus hätten sie so vor dem dreh sondern
35-jährigen sachbearbeiter vom finanzamt
einfach abgefangen gesagt so wie es für
uns typen also ja ich habe aber nur so
alltagsklamotten also absolut steinzeug
so ist doch kein stripper outfit diese
ja es ist nur für hilf mir okay ja das
ist eigentlich scheißegal
[Musik]
das ist ja ein trauriges
man merkt richtig wie sich so alle
unwohl fühlt
die tochter ist also die reaktion ist
auch kurven schnell dies nicht so wie
man sich denken würde wenn so ein
stripper aus der torte kommt dies aber
auch nicht so etwas ist dass dies so
mama schon wieder in strip er ist immer
gucken wir wissen dass es richtig kalt
ja okay ich sie wieder hinaus
[Musik]
das ist wieder für eine sinnlose kacke
das video läuft gerade 44 sekunden
das ist schon aus der torte juristischer
bauarbeiter sowie heraus gekommen den
sie natürlich instant rausschmeißt was
selbstverständlich auch eine selbst cool
aktion ist von ihr ich warte hat sich
schützend auf einer geburtstagsparty
report leute und da hatte ein kumpel von
mir
geburtstag feiert logischerweise auch
der überzeugt gemacht und einer von
seinen freunden hatte ihm eine
bauchtänzerin bestellt der bus ab geht
auf einmal eine bauchtänzerin da und hat
um ihnen getanzt so solche bauchtänzer
stripper sind auch menschen wie scheiße
was das sein verliefen die so anfangen
zu tanzen und noch zehn sekunden einfach
das geburtstagskind so ist raus
[Musik]
megas doch jeder
die anderen drei in dem raum sagen auch
kein wort hätte wahrscheinlich zu wenig
geld pokern gesagt hey 30 euro pro folge
sage ich nichts ich kann mich aber ich
sag nichts risiko also weißt du stumpf
so übertrieben die mimische reaktionen
aber keiner sagen wort naja ok das ist
natürlich auch sehr realistisch muss ich
sagen ist sehr gut die reaktion gute
story das ist so eine situation die wird
niemals passieren in keinem leben bei 3
den allermeisten fällen sind leute mit
25 keine jungfrau mehr dann wissen es
die besten freundin auf jeden fall ob
man jungfrau ist oder nicht und drittens
stellt uns aber es war auch nicht die
heilige mutter so asozial das
rauszuhauen vor den freunden falls das
nicht wissen sollten in diesem fall hier
in diesem sehr realistischen beispiel
liegen meine annahmen leider vollkommen
daneben
was hat sie gesagt das ist dein freund
jetzt habe ich das richtig verstanden
den strip hat er gerade aus dem kuchen
raus getanzt ist der sehr seltsam
aussehende stripper ist jetzt ihr freund
naja ok das macht sich natürlich auch am
liebsten würde lara jetzt natürlich im
erdboden versinken ja erde tut hier auf
den gedanken hatte ich auch schon bei
der einen oder anderen hilfe erfolge und
ihre mutter verhält sich auch mächtig
übergriffig denn was geht die mutter das
sexualleben der erwachsenen tochter
ich glaube
naja ok ist jetzt wieder ein extremer
kulturvolk nötig weil es eine minute 40
ist diese folge gelaufen und wir müssen
uns von unserer realität von dem was wir
aus dem echten leben kennen schon wieder
komplett verabschieden höhe solcher
geburtstag ist er jung frau mutter
bestellten stripper tochter mag es nicht
und setzt ihrer mutter einfach ein
kuchen ins gesicht aha sie kannte den
stripper das macht es auch nicht
wirklich beachtet außerdem an dieser
stelle bitte auch die wirklich
überzeugende mimi und diesen genialen
vortrag ich bin so sauber musste
wirklich sebastian heißen
ich musste wirklich so wie ich heiße
sehr geehrt dass ich mit ihm ich weiß
nicht ob ich mir diese videos ihr seht
oder ob es euch überhaupt interessiert
was ich zu sagen habe aber bitte keine
leute die sebastian heißen sonst stelle
ich mir vor wie das wäre wenn ich in der
situation
ich wollte einfach meine fragen berliner
holen und gehen auf einmal hat diesen
vortrag denken wir dass metzger
erfolgreich sind
beispiel stefan raab ja ja das ist so
als würde man sagen menschen mit rast
das sind erfolgreich und dann 7 und
ungarn als beispiel anführen
auch wenn er die abgeschnitten hat
stock davon halte das hat in meiner
metzgerei jetzt hier bitte damit zu tun
dass ich hier eine torte kaufen will und
warum was also ich sags doch ich sag's
doch er will einfach nur seinen kunden
kaufen und die alte lara button zu er
kann der met berüchtigten pickenpack an
der enz wie bild am sonntag
naja würden könnten sie eigentlich meine
tochter heiraten wie sie sind
verheiratet und meine tochter ist 30
jahre jünger als sie sie haben sich
verstanden dass das rtl 2 hier ist alles
möglich naja ok sie würde ihre eigene
tochter sofort nehmen weil sie essent
lecker sahneschnittchen natürlich nicht
mehr einfach nur ein sahneschnittchen
und ich will auch keine sahnehaube auf
meine torte wenn ich jemanden
kennenlernen will dann kann ich schon
ein dating oder sonstwohin ohne wird
sollte was mir gerade aufhält die
dialoge sind in dieser folge und das ist
wirklich das sticht heraus wirklich
besonders schlecht also die meisten
folgen erzählen die irgendwas macht noch
entfernt sind aber die rückkehr nur
scheiße er ist wirklich einfach nur
scheiße gelabert ja eher so wer hält
jemand treffen wir geht jetzt in der
dating agentur ist es eine dating
agentur und sie so ja bei den agenturen
kauft man die katze im sack
ach ja die aussage macht überhaupt
keinen sinn
aber hauptsache etwas gesagt leute das
macht überhaupt keinen sinn
er bildet horte sie sagt so jan nehmen
tun hat was auf gar keinen fall dort
heißt und dann so ja ok holz eine torte
aber nehmen erst mal tun hat und dann
noch meine tochter sahneschnittchen da
wusste auch nicht mehr zur dating
agentur ist sowas
donat nehmen sie ihre torte erhalten sie
alles und ich kann ihnen sagen wenn ich
was für untenrum suche ja dann kam
steuern für die roten laternen hängen da
brauche ich wenn ich was für untenrum
suche was heißt hat das ist auch keine
eindeutige aussage untenrum wofür suchst
du was untenrum fürs haus willst du
deinen keller einrichten oder so seine
hose nicht was für uns gefällt es
richtig märz aber guck mal da hat mir
gut gehen der metzgerei er sieht gut aus
das sind die richtigen fragen leute was
hat das alles mit der tochter zu tun
warum dreht sie jetzt ihre tochter
hilfenetz getan
diese begründung es geht jetzt wirklich
im kopf was sie gesagt hat sie hat so
ihrer tochter gegenüber als grund
angeführt dass sie mit dem 55-jährigen
metzger was anfangen soll
dass er je mettbrötchen machen kann
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend ich warte auf den richtigen
erstehen möchte ich aber wenn ich auf
dem richtigen immer gewartet hätte wärst
du nie entstanden wenn ich auf den
richtigen gewartet hätte willst du nicht
entstanden das heißt im umkehrschluss
dass sie einfach bei einer irgendwo
diesen random vögel entstanden ist dass
ihr vater auch einfach wahrscheinlich
überhaupt keine beziehung gehabt über
messen unfall korrekte mutter auf jeden
fall ist die ganzen aber auch der motor
warum geklappt hat doch gesehen 250
macht das einbetten
ich habe kein geld da war ich ja nicht
okay ich habe kein geld dabei bis zu tun
das ist so echt wie zahl für unsere
donuts
kleine rote kann ich auch sagen was als
nächstes passieren wird leute ihre
mutter steht ich bin da hinten bei
diesem hippie gitarren profi ihre mutter
wird sie als nächstes mit dem verkuppeln
selfphp ist und wie das dort werden wir
der nächsten folge sehen die morgen
kommt ich habe mich bis dahin hier noch
ein für euch vorgeschlagen das video
verlinkt das gerne ab und schaut bis
dahin hier schon mal weiter ab und wich
auf instagram unter escape falls es
nicht gemacht habe würde mich sehr
freuen und ja bis morgen